Do you ever feel like a fire breathing
dragonafter eating spicy food? Like your
throat is burning and you're about to exhale
a hot columnof flames? No? Just me? Makes me
wonder how dragons could breathe fire in the first
place. There are a lot of ideas how they might,
but my favorite is based on the real life
abilities of the Bombardier Beetle. This
beetle has one amazing defense mechanism to
protect itself frompredators. If threatened
it mixes a combination of hydrogen peroxide and
hydroquinones insidespecial chambers in its body,
creating a super- heated chemical reaction
that elevates to near boiling. Then this deadly
mixture is explosively sprayed on the beetle's
attacker. So maybe that's how dragons did it.
We maynever solve the mystery of fire breathing
inDragon lore unless nature
reveals it in real animals.
Between you and me I wouldn't want tostick
my head your dragon's mouth to find out.